في أوكرانيا ، ولكن ليس فقط منذ
الجلسة العامة الأخيرة ، أُجبر عشرات الآلاف من
المواطنين الأفغان على الفرار
بحثًا عن الطعام والأمان ،
ولكن كيف نفسر هذا التضامن
مع بولندا على سبيل المثال قبل أقل من
ثلاثة أشهر ، حقيقة أن 19 شخصًا
قد لقوا حتفهم من  البرد على حدودنا التقى
بالأسلاك الشائكة وخراطيم المياه
يواجه خمسة ملايين طفل مجاعة
وموت مؤلم ومؤلوم. زيادة 500
في حالات زواج الأطفال
ويتم بيع الأطفال لمجرد البقاء على قيد الحياة
وليس ذكر ذلك ليس هنا ولا في
أي مكان.  - تغطية تلفزيونية على الحائط ، لا توجد
استجابة إنسانية طارئة ،
ولا جلسات عامة خاصة ولا حتى ذكر
في هذه الجلسة العامة ، لا توجد وفود أفغانية
ولا
دولة يجب أن يتساءلوا ما الذي يجعل
أزمتهم الإنسانية غير مهمة ،
هل لون بشرتهم هو
أنهم ليسوا من البيض  إنهم ليسوا أوروبيين
لأن مشاكلهم تأتي من البندقية الأمريكية
أو غزو الولايات المتحدة هو أن
قرار سرقة ثروة بلادهم اتخذ من
قبل العلاقات العامة الاستبدادية الأمريكية  مقيم
وليس روسي
[موسيقى]
لأن يا إلهي كل الحروب شريرة وكل
الضحايا يستحقون الدعم وإلى أن نصل
إلى تلك الصفحة ، فليس لدينا مصداقية
على الإطلاق